شركه جوجل تعمل على اعاده تصميم محرك
البحث الخاص بها لي تنتقل الى شكل جديد
يحاكي شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
جوجل سوف يتضمن اضافه مزايا جديده مثل عرض
مقاطع فيديو قصيره على غرار شبكات
اجتماعيه مثل التيك توك وانستجرام جوجل
تعتزم ايضا تضمين المزيد من نتائج البحث
في موضوعات منشوره على الانترنت هذا يعني
انها قد تعطي هذه المنشورات افضليه في
الظهور ضمن نتائج البحث المتقدم الميزه
الاكبر جوجل دردشه
الخاص المدعم بالذكاء الاصطناعي والذي
تطلق عليه اسم براد او اسم
محرك البحث براد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات